joining me now is ari fleischer from
white house press secretary fox news
contributor and amela epinobi prageru
personality former left-wing activist
ari
this is so transparent what they're
doing with the student debt forgiveness
it's insulting and it obviously just
adds to our economic woes
you know and it's just morally wrong
why is it student debt why is it why is
the college
why isn't it your card debt why isn't
your home debt why isn't it all debt i
mean what a burden nobody should have to
pay any of their bills it's wrong to
make people pay the bills that they
incurred you know what about all the
rest of us who do pay our bills who do
pay our debts unemployment as president
biden loves to point out is low people
have jobs they have money so
they need to pay their bills laura this
is just buying votes as the democrats
always try to do but it's also an
example of how the democrats are
increasingly becoming the party of the
rich these are the well-to-do college
graduates master's degree holding
college graduates just like they want to
go bring back the relief if you pay your
state and local income taxes get to
deduct all those which benefit wealthy
people with big houses in in the mostly
coastal states
democrats have changed their but their
roots and their base that the party of
the rich
they're losing young people they're
losing hispanic voters amla but this
student loan forgiveness as has already
said that's targeted toward the young
voters who are saying what this isn't
what wasn't what we thought we were
buying we bought biden my question comes
august they're obviously going to extend
it again
is this going to work
are you guys cheap dates
you know i you you'll be hard-pressed to
meet a young person who doesn't love the
word free and when it comes to student
loan debt they love to hear that they
love to hear that it's going to be
forgiven but what about all the other
families and students who have already
paid off their loans i didn't force
anybody to go and sign a loan for fifty
thousand dollars to go to school they
can keep trying to run on this lie that
they're going to forgive this to people
but that's all it is you see people like
chuck schumer put out on twitter today
would be a great day to cancel student
loan debt and i want to tell people
that's all it's ever going to be it's
only ever going to be a tweet they're
not going to do this for you and you
shouldn't be fooled into thinking that
they will it's the very same thing that
they do with black lives matter every
single election cycle suddenly they care
about black lives and they're going to
do all this stuff for the black
community and as soon as they're voted
in nothing happens so people need to
start waking up to this
well speaking of schumer ari he just
continues to reveal for a man who's been
in congress since the 80s he continues
to reveal a basic economic ignorance
watch
it's amazing to me
that we could just take a burden off
people's shoulders
so easily with the flick of a pen the
president can do it student debt is one
of the very biggest things holding our
economy back i have told the president
this is one of the most important things
he can do to help our economy grow
well he's just reading whatever the
person's speech writer or whatever wrote
for him he's that he's reading it number
one but ari that's the biggest thing we
could do to like what do you say get the
economy going or helped it really that's
their idea for growing the economy
yeah they never talk about economic
growth they never talk about
circumstances in the environment to let
the private sector boom give people
higher paying better jobs that all comes
from the private sector it doesn't come
from the heavy hand of government but
the common theme throughout all these
democrats slash socialist policies is
that life should be free and that we in
the government are here to make sure you
have no financial
burdens requirements needs because the
government will forgive you it can't
work that way this is why socialist
countries got doomed they gave away too
much free stuff we as americans are too
sensible we know this won't work
we know it's not right and when you
incur a debt you have an obligation to
pay the debt
it doesn't get more complicated than
that if you lose your job you're
unemployed there are emergency systems
that kick in to prevent you from having
to go under or pay those bills but as a
general matter no you incur a debt you
pay a debt now
don't borrow what you can't pay back the
old sayings of your parents rights my
mom used to say don't borrow it you
can't pay it back amela i've got to say
democrats do have some
top priorities and one of them seems to
be
prohibiting
hair discrimination a washington post
op-ed
critics have argued that the crown act
is redundant because the civil rights
act of 1964 already offers protections
against racial discrimination but
supporters of the bill rightly point out
that clearer language is necessary amla
this is geared toward
minority voters african-american uh
women i know this is popular with some
of them
uh will this help
stem the tide of black voters who are
also looking
at alternatives other than the democrats
you know i think they are just grasping
at straws at this point a bill
surrounding discrimination around black
hair are you kidding me i have never
heard of a more ridiculous thing and am
i saying that people should be
discriminated against based on their
hair absolutely not but it is is it a
pervasive problem that we need to be
focusing our time our money and our
resources on as a country absolutely not
and i think it's because they're
realizing that black voters are looking
at the words that they're saying and
it's not matching up to their actions so
again they're grasping at straws trying
to push this racist white supremacist
narrative that they run with every
single election cycle in hopes of
gaining those votes back and i don't
think it's gonna work
no it's sad ari you know what else was
said
today at the end of another biden's
speech
this happened
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well first of all ari he went to shake
the hand of someone who wasn't there and
then he kind of does that
what's going on all right
did of course no bush would never allow
his staff would never allow something
like that to happen it wouldn't happen
but where's the staff
why does this keep happening
well let me let me try to be kind and
gen maybe he he was just gesticulating
with his hand maybe it wasn't really him
shaking the air i don't know
but man laura he's lost he's wandering
lost on a stage presidents don't do that
you have crisp clear instructions you
finish you turn you go out stage left
stage right
he was told that ahead of time there's
usually a chart backstage that actually
shows him physically with arrows
so
he was lost he was lost on a stage after
giving a speech and it's
it's physically mentally sad to see
now ari and amalah thank you so much hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else